un gesto de Victoria sus partidarios
Branham sale del tribunal bajo una
fuerte escolta policial pero libre el ex
Primer Ministro quedó en Libertad bajo
fianza fue detenido el martes cuando
compareció ante el tribunal en un caso
de corrupción el viernes pudo dar su
versión de los hechos
estaba dentro del tribunal superior no
tenían ningún motivo para detenerme me
llevaron me enseñaron una orden de
detención por primera vez dentro de la
cárcel esto se llama la ley de la selva
me secuestraron
una detención que provocó indignación y
desencadenó una ola de disturbios en el
país
reunido cerca de la casa de sus
partidarios recibieron la noticia con
alivio Mientras que el actual Primer
Ministro pakistaní se mostró
desconcertado por el inicio de una
conversación entre Hannah y el
presidente del tribunal supremo ayer el
presidente del tribunal supremo de
Pakistán le dijo a Irán encantado de
conocerle y en un caso así del que no
hay ejemplos y Alguien ha cometido
corrupción eso es algo inverosímil un
acusado llega al tribunal y el juez le
dice ha sido un placer conocerle con
esta decisión y está a salvo de una
nueva detención durante dos semanas sin
embargo el jueves el ministro del
interior prometió que sería de nuevo han
de su lado denuncia un intento del
gobierno y del ejército de impedir su
regreso al poder